maybe there's some day in long future
where all the work is being done by
robotic devices but in that case we
should be in such an advanced society
where they're creating the wealth for us
while we can just do what we want to do
tell us about honeybee and some of the
things you build here our biggest client
is NASA we have placed some important
equipment on two of the Rovers that are
still operating on Mars Burnie we're
gonna start off with a vodka and tonic
place it would be my pleasure
here at honeybee we invented the first
robotic bartender and we are hoping to
develop a robotic surgical tool the
robot can enter through a cavity that's
very tiny so the person has a short
recovery time but it's not just that the
robot can also make very very tiny
movements the notion is that sometimes
you want to do something that's so
really really precise that a tiny laser
cut let's say well this these devices
allow you to change the settings on it
so you could propel this device in two
inches but on the output it along it cut
something 2007 meet the world's first
artificial intelligence personal robot
she's your welcome friend at any hour
good morning Thomas time to get up good
morning it seems like you had a good
night's sleep eight full hours and a
good resting heart rate thank you so
tell me a little bit about Maya
take one months old we launched on
Kickstarter about a month ago
come on let's let's go into the kitchen
a general robot see when you'll be one
robot I can do a lot of different things
and by doing that you just install
different apps on Maya Maya take a
picture
two three
Maya what is this fun lets you send
handwritten notes and your own
handwriting or any handwriting you
choose on personalized stationery from
any device and we build software that
can learn all of the nuance of how you
write or you can pick from other
different kinds of handwriting styles
now when you selling something with your
hand it is to show that you you've given
the product to a human touch is it
deception to use a machine to do this
for you so I mean I don't believe that
it's a deceptive practice to use a
machine just like I don't believe it's a
deceptive practice using machine to
communicate when you're far away
that's called a telephone I've come
across so many people have been afraid
about robotics replacing people and
we've been installing robots here at
honeybee since the early 80s and I've
never seen a job be replaced that did
not create at least one or two other
jobs are you putting the calligraphers
of the world out of business
is that because we actually staffed like
her first in our company but we think we
create an environment where more people
are interested in learning calligraphy
and creating beautiful things hey need
some help in here could you pull up a
recipe for chicken curry please I'll
walk you through it step by step if you
don't see the future being filled with
robots that are indistinguishable from
humans I don't think that's the way to
look at it that's our first prototype
out there I mean we would view it at a
beginning like a human right the way we
didn't see any value from doing that she
good at things like remember 5,000
people faces I can't do that they got me
good at things that I didn't let me good
at this one good at look robotic
techniques now are advancing so much in
the end the robots are going to win but
this will free people up to do other
things I'm not afraid of it
we built them
goodnight